how's it going [ __ ] I mean bros my
name is PewDiePie and welcome back to
Bali for the 21st [ __ ] time we
are going to where do you want to go
what do you what do you feel like
venturing today there's a lot of stuff
on the map I'm waiting for an answer
Jeremy moon I'm just kidding it's okay
that's okay you don't feel like chatting
I read your mind anyway hahaha we go
into town
hey that's boy yeah alright what is what
the [ __ ] is this
finding Johnny Vince not Mike Oh where'd
he go Dan you [ __ ]
yeah try and brain I got Johnny not
exclusively I'll grant you but I loved
him now he's gone hey nice Valley bottom
brown Johnny's disappeared gone crazy
abducted by aliens you hopkins
yeah my man aliens you turned up
everything's gone really weird king of
the series it is jealous of my heart ah
my love has gone find him poking me
you're both acting crazy cut it out
yeah tell me where's Johnny the [ __ ]
got it no nobody's seen him he got
really crying hearted after we split up
but it's not my fault someone said they
saw a couple of asylum orderlies driving
up to his house no not just I let me get
on Johnny wasn't crazy
silent orderly ah yo leader not like you
Jimmy
I want to slug get your boy back our
[ __ ] no later freaks
I wish they're still there so I can slap
them alright so we're gonna find Johnny
by going to the [ __ ] a slim God [ __ ]
MA
I don't even know what I just said
but it's a long [ __ ] trip that's for
sure you got to go through school
oh yeah Ronnie MA
yeah whoa whoa whoa calm down all right
it should be here somewhere
hey Aaron I'm a [ __ ] monkey
that's what I am trip tree passing good
ha ha ha ha
shut up all right
can't we just kill all of them or do I
really have to like what is that guy
doing with a mask outside
is he gonna see me and n woman aren't
you going yes yes oh my god oh my god oh
my god hello yeah oh my god you remember
first episode course you do
wah wah wah snaky pills activate ha ha
ha opens the door like this oh [ __ ] okay
I don't know how I know we're in this I
saw a slim here but I apparently know
that he's in it and I know that I don't
care but he sure does yellow line
who johnny-boy all right let's see if we
can do this oh lucky me he went in the
other way don't turn around
doctor
go go go go go go go go go yes yes yes
run runnin runnin runnin runnin runnin
going in here goin in hand goal winning
in Goa Nene what's up my [ __ ] what's
up what's up my [ __ ] stuff well that
was close
no he's not even here anymore butts
[ __ ] make it easier for you
like I'm some kind of stupid person
guess I am a bount I am die aren't we
all Jace's [ __ ] did he ever [ __ ] Jesus
didn't have any babies all right what am
i doin supposed to be stuffing alright
we're good we good we good we good
No what the [ __ ] is he doing
if it gets me I how does he not see my
hat my glorious hat oh [ __ ] I got oh it
is him well I'll be damned
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm scared I do
not want to run egg running oh shut up
get an orderly uniform from the laundry
room dropouts I'm not here for you
alright I am here for you but get to the
laundry room I can't even get to your
room how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
this wow you don't see my idea stupid
[ __ ]
running okay we're going in here then
after this store I have literally no
plan huh running showers don't you tread
sub whoa whoa
yes I'm awesome at South quest now I can
just walk around and [ __ ] with paper
hey what's up hey come here come a
shower with me
hey shower with me come here
shower with me shower with me shower
with me won't you
you okay you okay there you want a
shower with me you want a shower with me
what's new what's new man ah why does no
one want a shower with me I don't
understand
we could have so much hello will you
want a shower with me
now that's okay you want your break man
this is so boring well you're doing a
shitty job anyway so good job hey this
is a control room all right Oh BAM yay
yay yay
all right we're gonna help Johnny what's
up Johnny
what that guy do it [ __ ] creepy all
right I got this
now three enemies are gonna hear if I
know this game whoa we got to do
something away about this I'm so strong
motherfuckas Ranjan Aron
run honey Roo campus new all right that
was pretty [ __ ] easy thanks for
getting me out Jimmy no problem but you
get in there to begin yeah exactly what
a local kid said they'd gotten together
with Lola I went a little crazy I can't
believe that I I can't I gotta find low
let's see if it's true or not see you
all right Johnny how about we just
Oh Greece I respect mother [ __ ] III
don't get everything in it you might be
able to help why do you need help I got
out you helped me get them back
yes well alright appreciate it hey give
me a hug
I want a hug please hug me hey I love
you give me a hug plate
I'd do anything if you will give me a
hug you [ __ ] you know what you know
what you know what I'm taking protect
I'm taking mr. Jay with Jonathan I'm
taking picture of your nipples don't
cover them that's right that's right I
did it Jonathan Jay we Jonathan it's
that don't cover your nipples no oh you
won this round Jaime Jonathan but the
next one you won't be so lucky
bust up I think this game had more to it
than er than I thought
from the beginning it looks like it has
a lot more why did the taxi driver go
who drove in that bus it wasn't a taxi
though but what the [ __ ] Olli over that
guy naylet oh we have a tiny people
alright what quest can we do now we can
do one in school you want to do one in
school Bros that's I'm good I'm just
trying to be asked now that I did want
you to enjoy yourself are you enjoying
that maybe you want a snack I have this
cup if you want you want it how you can
have it chemistry well I'm pretty good
at the chemistry lab stations all right
let's do this
I actually have an appropriate to
creative now and for God's sake don't
eat all right I'm gonna come up with a
different word for you Schlatter let's
see if I can do this
Salman gwendy David
sandals animal wedgie wacker wanker
Wanda snorted voila Monda hawala pal
manda
are you drunk I thought I had that one I
thought I had that one [ __ ] now it's
gonna go again
all right stable Wendy David Sandalow
ain't no wedgie Ram it Ram world wide is
sassy sassy whammy I know
vodka you angelic my eyes doo-doo-doo no
never do bling okay well I did it at
least you can't complain I'm getting
good at this I'm getting [ __ ]
good at this
the doctor base girl hey what's up
where the hell am i goin and under
baddest no one a shakadou to fly the
weather weather when the father but I
think this coffee I just drank it's
doing things to me
look hey my ball my ball my ball yeah my
ball my ball my ball it's my boss
yes an umbrella I was that umbrella
under my umbrella my umbrella
to Narnia and then why I'm so pretty
under amber Allah Allah Allah
a under my umbrella ah here we are
finally Jesus a took forever revenge on
mr. Burton hello
said while you live sassy Belen girl
what are you looking at nothing your
tail looks like you're looking at me
scumbag it's nothing
oh come on I don't want to fight you my
name is Jimmy
my name is Jimmy I want to motor but now
Zoe I was at Bulworth once I got kicked
out why sure let's just say mr. Burton
is a dirty creeps seriously I would love
to teach that guy a lesson he bullies
everyone who's nice effective he goes
jogging every day and regularly uses the
porta-potties in the park yeah Isaac
sucks we could catch him in one on top
of a hill then mr. Burton could have a
really interesting time in it yeah but
they're all chained together we'll need
to get some bolt cutters go get some
from the spaz industries building and
meet me at the park okay where no one
sees you uh um I'm really good at that
thing in particular okay sounds easy
enough
where is it oh oh oh no I don't want to
do it unless you are Jesus that's it
forever did you get them yeah yeah now
what now way always goes to the can when
he goes running we've got to make sure
he uses this
send him on a trip oh this sounds
awesome that's the most awkward way to
hand someone ever yes
you make sure he doesn't use one of the
other modes this sounds like it's gonna
be good haha destroy the parties before
mr. Brydon finished oh [ __ ] alright [ __ ]
literally ha ha ha ha ha ha kids your
jokes are always so original ha ha ha ha
ha ha alright let's see if i can go am i
there I think I'm the only one who can
never ever [ __ ] ever
not not Taylor Swift but like get down
this please [ __ ] me it's a I don't even
know need to go that way I'll do it
later I'll do it later we don't have a
lot of time hmm boom jump on we're down
below which one first I think what this
one here it would be quite lovely
because it's right over here
alright what do we need to do here
exactly how do I destroy them Wow does
that it I just punch it look oh there he
is
I can [ __ ] see him now I know who it
is at least oh she is returning soon
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] just hit it everyone
knows he has to take a [ __ ] after he
runs vandalism it's called purple
delicious I don't even know why do I
even try anymore
I got a gnome what are you doing dog
dog ate shut up wow that looks nice
shut up doc doc shut up [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah dog and stop you're so obnoxious
dog
music [ __ ]
toy head toy you toilet that's ash
ball one yeah haha that's lovely
oh yeah god damn I stink I'm gonna have
to shower for days with please what I
got hazed oh it's [ __ ] stuck the ha
ha ha hey bum-bum-bum [ __ ] awesome I
love this game I love it can I please
try this
I can drive - shut up hey that's my
baseball bat my freshman backed mine
take it take the baseball bat I dare you
take it
this is a beauty my baseball bat let's
see you top shot ah all right I'm going
yeah so fast yay yah
oh that did not work out as I wanted it
nah [ __ ] alright here we finally are I
took me a while what's up Greaseballs
did you guys steal the preppies trophies
why would they say it anyway after the
town he's been saying all that stuff
about Lola and made Johny crazy we don't
care about those stuck-up jerks
ya know Sokka really yeah oh yeah it's a
townie no friend of ours anymore
but since you got him out I'll let you
walk away from this meeting well since I
already beat you I guess I believe you
but I'm gonna beat you anyway hahaha Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam alright that was
fun
ah Vespa Vespa what are you doing here
best buy my beer day what are you doing
all right I love you last but you are
the greater and what about there shall I
beat him fight we're going here
ah [ __ ] you Vespa
where is it here
here best buy done black man find the
town is putting rats in crates oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
he nearly saw me that was [ __ ] close
ah that's nasty
[ __ ] are you guys doing that's my rat ha
ha what am I doing with this thing why
did I take it oh [ __ ] they do a lot of
damage
Hey quit squirming man our hope one that
invites the librarian see there we go
what am I supposed to do find the time
if internet and get a picture all right
there we go alligator just stays there
posing I'm gonna get up hahahaha I want
the rats back though no what no no I
fell down I think I played too much de
bras and we're saving all right breasts
like a pirate if you enjoy it helps out
a lot
Fitz can I become a little too toy and I
feel me